son temps je vais on entre en mode
panique quand ça arrive le début du
cauchemar pour marié vos brice et en
2006 elle tente de contracter des
assurances pour se rendre compte qu'elle
s'est fait usurper son identité
après s'être fait voler son numéro
d'assurance sociale plusieurs années
auparavant
on fait le tour en fait on se rend
compte que c'est la débandade lé
complètement ses ultras tentaculaire sur
tous les pans de la vie donc super
dossier
depuis elle ne compte plus les problèmes
liés à ce vol d'identité des centaines
de dollars de contraventions pour des
infractions au code de la route
l'interruption de ses prestations
familiales et l'a même fait l'objet d'un
mandat d'arrestation logement quelle
ressource
je me disais comme faire un peu
n'importe quand je sais pas comment
faire il faut que ça sorte n'a aucun bon
sens le cas de marie-eve est
malheureusement loin d'être unique
la sûreté du québec audimatiques depuis
2003 une augmentation d'environ 80 pour
sa vie fraude c'est quand même beaucoup
les techniques des fraudeurs sont
multiples et se raffine les outils aussi
comme cette application donc givaudan
russes qu'ils font c'est qu'ils vont
vous appelez avec un numéroté de femme
d'un espion financière c'est ce que je
viens de faire la svo d'airbus votre
achat vous allez voir un numéro qui va
apparaître
et lorsque vous rappeler une façon
simple de recueillir vos données
personnelles en se faisant passer pour
le représentant d'une institution
financière
c'est tout en quelques semaines quelques
mois plus tard qu'on s'en aperçoit les
stratagèmes et les histoires d'horreur
silvey envoie à tous les jours il croit
qu'il faut revoir la législation pour
mieux protéger les victimes de fraude et
de vol d'identité comme marie-eve quand
on regarde au canada ça peut représenter
un industrie de deux milliards par année
donc il faut absolument qu'il y ait des
lois beaucoup plus sévères pour les
fraudeurs
moi j'aimerais bien rencontrer rennaise
la justice pour me dire mon côté je suis
pas tout seul
qu'est ce qui va arriver qu'est ce qui
va être fait en fait parce que l'autre
difficulté c'est le peu de ressources
disponibles pour venir en aide aux
victimes de vol d'identité
j'attendrai ce serait quand même bon de
rappeler ce qu'il faut faire si on est
ou si on croit être victime d'une telle
fraude
dans les cas de vol d'identité la
première chose à faire c'est porter
plainte à la police de plusieurs
victimes qui ne le font pas ensuite j'ai
contacté des entreprises comme equifax
ou transunion pour faire mettre un
message de fraude sur votre compte
mais pour reprendre les mots de monsieur
paquet ce genre d'entreprises offrent un
service qui ressemble en fait un
détecteur de fumée donc ça n'appelle pas
les pompiers lorsque le feu est pris
chez vous et c'est là que les victimes
se retrouvent dans un ayant par un
manque de ressources parce que le
fardeau de la preuve repose sur vous
alors le bureau canadien du crédit peut
vous aider à monter cette preuve c'est
parfois couverts par les assurances
habitation et pour ce qui est de
l'assurance sociale du numéro
d'assurance sociale c'est très difficile
d'en obtenir un nouveau mariage aubry
attend toujours son nouveau numéro
d'assurance sociale qu'ils ont plus tard
qui l'histoire merci beaucoup jacques
audrey